i i don't i know it varies for every
girl so imagine a guy that has every
single thing that you want like perfect
guy
would you overlook cheating
from time to time
just a side chick no i would you would
you'd overlook it i wouldn't you
wouldn't even if also your bills are
taken care of completely until you die i
wouldn't you wouldn't okay
i wouldn't um if i had kids they might
be different but i didn't say too yeah
if i didn't have kids
um and i was still i felt like
if i was still like maybe my age now
um
yeah
i wouldn't overlook it because a trait
that i look for is loyalty
and
for me i understand that the
male nature is to spread his seed you
know go find out what like what he wants
and
yeah so i i can understand that but i
also think that them given into that
nature of you know like even if it
didn't mean anything it was just like a
one-night stand you know he was just
caught up in the moment
that to me would
be like you're you're a weak man you
can't hold like especially if we had
something really good going on
and we had a really good relationship
we'd been together a really long time
and
and then you just [ __ ] up one night
like that to me is
disrespectful to me and then i wouldn't
go back with you because
now you would probably do that again
because i've accepted that that's how
you are now you [ __ ] up from time to
time can i just ask have you been in
that position before
no i've never been done
that you know
so for you why did you say yes
i don't believe that men
can not cheat okay and when i say men i
mean most men
i think i think i think they're just
built to
i think
you're dating the twenty percent you
mean we're not designing they're not
designed to be with one person don't say
we're not designed to cheat because
that's because you're assuming that the
woman is
like somehow like deserving of just me
alone no no no no no what makes you
think she's saying on desire to be
monogamous but no no that's not her
words hey let her say what she's saying
she said yeah guys let her talk she said
cheat guys let her talk go ahead go
ahead hello
yeah i don't i don't believe that men
can just be with one person is that from
experience you've been like cheated on a
lot i've in fact i've been cheated on
but i've never found out until when i
was it was way way way away something
it's never affected me but
i kind of feel like
it's a
scientific or genetic whatever you want
to what however you want to put it i i
feel like men they they think with their
penises and
i wouldn't i personally if i was with
someone for many many years and then i
found out that they cheated on me i
wouldn't throw away a whole
that you know that whole sort of
relationship for for one person
who was probably insignificant i
wouldn't i wouldn't because she did
that's that that was the difference so
she did say
if it was a side chick like having a
relationship on the side you'd still be
speaking to them
oh sorry if it wasn't a one night stand
if it was a one night stand or
a relationship over a period of time is
that both acceptable
yeah
okay and would you think if
if he does cheat on you would you think
that he still loves you yeah i would i
don't i don't think i don't think i
don't think a man cheating means he
doesn't love his his partner agreed
because i think i think
not to be controversial but monogamy is
a social construct yeah which isn't bad
it's you know it it works for our
society and it's very much if without a
society societal conscious social
construct we would do what we want we
would do as we please we brought right
back down to our biology exactly the
twenty percent will get the eighty
percent so because we have everywhere
because we have to stay with one woman
in in the west it enables more men to
have a woman if if they had polygamy
yeah the best men would get the best
wives
but uh
i mean
i mean i do i do i do think men are
biologically predispositioned to cheap
but i also think you can make choices to
not put yourself in those situations
yeah um so i i kind of i kind of
understand what both of you guys are
saying because i one hand i really do
think
a lot of guys if it's thrown at them are
going to have a really hard time turning
it down and there's going to be a very
like like tiger woods i think of right
he he had that whole
he like facebook groups full of women
right and then like that man was wildin
but but like most guys don't have a a
bus full of brazilian models waiting for
them at the end of a golf course i think
most men couldn't turn that down but at
the same time like my dad never cheated
on my mom right and he's in the top half
a percent of earners but he just doesn't
drink and doesn't put himself in those
situations
so
i know i was very good at it i don't
think just because you're biologically
predisposed to to cheat
or to be polygamous i don't
i don't think that means you need to act
on it what i would say as an example
is if
it's it's
men are biologically predispositioned to
violence far more than women okay
now if a man started to bat the [ __ ] out
of somebody in the street what's the
first thing we'd all say
why can't you control yourself yeah
right so i think you can also apply it
to this i think
this is going to piss a lot of men off
i'm sorry but the truth of the matter is
yes i will agree you are biologically
predispositioned to to have more than
one woman or seek out more than one
woman spread your seed so to call it
right
that doesn't mean you need to act on it
and i think as a man you can
truly be happy long-term yeah without
acting on it
i think you can do that
but it's
a bit controversial go ahead like it's
men are more loyal to their friends than
they are they're women sometimes
men will not sleep with her friends if
if men
will say i'm not sleeping with a girl
that's being with their friend or that's
a friend's ex that's not loyal
but they'll sleep around behind the
woman they're supposed to love more than
anything's back like no no the reason
why i don't sleep with my friends the
girl that's been with my friend is
because i don't like i don't want
no i'm not saying the woman that's slept
around i'm saying if your friend was in
a relationship with a girl or
like someone your friend not even a
relationship say your friend had fancied
a girl who liked a girl and had told you
you probably wouldn't go there because
of your friend but what i'm saying to
you is you will go behind you will sleep
out of your marital beds but that's not
that's not because because men show
loyalty to women in different ways yeah
and so so them is protection and
provisioning that's like that's how they
show loyalty okay and so you're put
you're protecting they're not protected
i sleep it's sleeping around that's not
very good no no no
it's resources right there they're not
perfect for it's in protection so if
someone breaks into your house who's
expected to go
go fight the robber or whatever it is
that's protection but if with their
friends like they don't get their
protection and provisioning yeah you're
judging us by the woman's measuring
stick yeah
i don't think that means men are more
loyal to their friends than their
partners we as men we provide a
different set of values for you so
though a man may cheat
the values that he is providing to you
again
it all goes back to
the way we are on a biological level
this isn't agreed upon by most people
from what i've seen yeah
but the science is very clear that we
are all still our brains are still
ancient that's just the truth of matter
so if you're gonna act out of impulse
that's a biological impulse and your
brain the decisions that you make the
way you think is actually still very
primal so for a man to look at another
woman and cheat now i'm not saying he
has to do it you can't argue a man for
the impulse
for the lust
and i would even go as far as to say
acting on it however the values that he
provides you
are
physical security
now in modern day times
financial security
okay
and
ultimately he can go out and fend for
himself and get all of the resources
needed
i think ultimately women care more about
those traits those qualities that a man
can provide if he used to [ __ ] up and
accidentally sleep with a woman but he
can still provide all of those things
for you i think
and it i think it also does depend on
age right so if you're younger you're
far more likely to go i've got no real
investment in this man fine i can move
on but i've i can see many situations in
my life and we probably all can where
the man
so she's invested in a man to such that
she's now got a house on a mortgage
she's now got many many kids they are
married one slip up i think if women are
deep down honest with themselves they'll
admit that one slip up i don't think it
does anything
i don't think i don't think it means he
loves me any less it does nothing
having a whole other relationship that's
detrimental okay but that's that's
different yeah that is different
a relationship is very different yeah
honestly the older generation still got
through that they did yeah they did i
know so many grandparents that had like
side chicks for a hot minute and i don't
i don't agree with it
but i think they were just kind of built
of a different cloth right
would you would you accept you would i
accept cheating i always say if i had
kids it's not about me anymore because
once you have kids you put the kids
first so if i had kids no i i if i had
kids i would accept it if i
didn't have kids now i'm leaving
on the flip side of that if
if we're accepting
cheating and our children are also
seeing
the aftermath of that
what
well
it's it's very small well the kids
shouldn't know i mean i i'm sorry but
yeah that's just the responsibility
that's irresponsible to let your kids
know what your marriage problems are
kids kids know a lot and they don't say
so you might you might not necessarily
want your kids to know or even know that
your children know but
you know they're they're not how how
would kids know that he cheated
not necessarily that he cheated but say
for instance
they might
say for instance i was with i was with
my partner and
he cheated and and that
affected me in a way where i was
completely depressed for a whole year
that's going to affect the children
right you're depressed yeah but
that's that's yeah but if i'm depressed
i can't look after my children properly
that's a choice that's your that's yours
you're depressed well it's not it's not
it's not a health problem because it's
effective okay okay but but you
shouldn't let it affect your kids
wait hold on hold on hold on you said
what so if councilman is okay
you had a lot of you got a lot of
depression is is a mental health issue
yeah you can't say oh you shouldn't be
depressed that doesn't make sense i'm
saying you can be sad and you you can be
depressed but the way you act is a
choice and you should be a mother first
and put you before and put your kids
before you it's not about you anymore
once you have children but you could try
to put them first but ultimately
sometimes for some people you can get
yeah you can you could get help but i'm
saying that help could take a whole year
that that rebuilding of yourself could
take a whole year or six months
what's the alternative right because the
alternative is putting your kid at a
statistical disadvantage
there's a there's a single
mother-to-prison pipeline so if i put my
i put the i put my kid at the
disadvantage not the man that cheated
now
where does the responsibility
why is it why because it's whoever it's
whoever it's who breaks up the home who
leaves
whoever
wait a minute yeah hold on yeah but we
we also said that in cases of domestic
violence it's different like yeah so
what i'm saying is so
i'm with i've i've told to my partner
that i'm gonna have kids with if you
cheat i'm leaving he's decided to cheat
on me and i have left now i've made my
kids become a statistic that's what
you're saying
only if you act a certain way only if
you act a certain way my fault wait let
me explain it okay okay okay i think
it's i think we can agree common sense
right yeah if you break up your home
then you
leave your kids at a statistical
disadvantage yeah whether it's your
fault
so therefore if a man then then goes out
and cheats then it's isn't it him that
breaks he's broken no because he's
breaking the contract he didn't leave he
didn't leave the marriage
ultimately
you are the catalan you're the catalyst
right right but you're putting yourself
before your children as the mother you
are not so you're supposed to love your
kids more than yourself so did he play
himself before all of us can i quickly
ask a question sorry right this now this
is aside from
cheating
if a man was struggling financially
wasn't doing too well with money
he couldn't find a job or he was down in
the dumps and his ability to provide had
now been knocked
if he was to to basically just sit
around and mope and act all depressed
what would you say to him
i'm going to help you get up and get
back on your feet and get back maybe in
the beginning but as time goes because a
minute ago your example was for a year
if i'm depressed does he have a year to
be depressed and not get [ __ ] done you
would now turn around and look at them
and go bollocks to that your feelings
come second to us and the kids and what
goes on in the household and the
security
i think i think that is a massive double
standard i think that that example is a
bit different yeah i would because the
guy loses his job outside of outside but
i did state from the beginning that he
is aside from the date but
ultimately where it's the same principle
it's one minute i'm depressed and i'm
putting that on my kids and they're
suffering and if a man is depressed and
he's putting out on the kids and now the
wife and the kids are suffering her her
attitude is you need to man up and get
on with it so why is a woman can you not
put it aside and just get on with it why
do the kids have to suffer
for me personally it's easy for you to
say that but if if i was in a position
where my partner cheated on me however
that affects me it can affect me forever
long i can't i would i would hate for
somebody to say put that aside for the
because of the kids in the woman's sake
i would argue i would absolutely argue
it's because they are far more emotional
either way either it's natural it's easy
for you to do something to hurt somebody
and to say oh get over it because of the
kids i feel like that i understand where
you're coming from but if you're the one
causing that pain you can't then be the
same one saying get over it but you but
you but you can mask it to the point
where the kids don't need to suffer in
both cases
that's what i'm saying i'm saying it's
about the kids it's not about your
personal feelings it's about your
children yeah so
can i just clarify that
so we've got married
you know if you cheat that i can't
cannot stay with you because it will
kill me inside it'll make me a
whatever oh my god terrible
so you cheat we have kids you cheat
it it is selfish to cheat no no i know
what you're saying so
he's cheated i i haven't done anything
i'm at home playing with my kid with our
kids okay i've done something so he
cheated but and then
shut up if i leave
it's my okay who's whose feelings are
more important the kids are you
everyone's no whose feelings are more
important because me and the kids that's
that he does not matter
who's whose feelings are more important
the kids are you
it has to be the kids okay okay so say i
let it go once then for the kids what
happens if you choose again
this is this the same question still
posted no way are you kidding me that i
have to stay here no no no no no no no
i'm not holding on for nothing i've got
the car keys